you know what no I don't want to work
with you know if you'll excuse me I'm
out of here
sindhya and Bella can you two just hug
it out already we can't stand to see
Hollywood breaking up friendships you
two have been through a lot together we
love it when you support one another and
lift each other up and this crazy world
we live in
girlfriends need to stick together it's
time to show Hollywood who's the boss
your friendship is too special to let
anything come between it ever again
bella thorne and gin daya Colman have
known each other ever since they
co-starred and Disney Channel's shake it
up when they were just kids but their
relationship has hit a few rough patches
so are they friends enemies or frenemies
here's the truth about zendaya and
Bella's friendship the year was 2010
zendaya was only 14 years old and Bella
Thorne was 13 they landed the roles of
rocky and Cece on Disney Channel's shake
it up they instantly became friends but
throughout the show that friendship got
pretty Rocky
in an exclusive interview with j14 Bella
shared that she didn't always get along
with her co-star Bella revealed that
there was a lot of pressure from outside
influences forcing the girls to compete
against each other Bella said that she
and zendaya were put in a very
unfortunate position where they were
pitted against one another that made the
first season of the show extremely
awkward for the cast mates Bella went on
to say that they really wanted to love
each other but they were being tricked
into competing with each other instead
they would ask the girls who was better
at this and he was better at that that
made for a lot of tension on set
thankfully they were able to navigate
those choppy waters in the second season
Bella share that she got together with
us India and they confessed everything
to each other she said they just had
this tell-all discussion they started
crying and really bare their souls that
was the moment when they became best
friends
according to Bella felons and dais
friendship wavered once they left the
Disney Channel to pursue different paths
however they did come together for the
women's March in Washington DC in 2017
the two stars were among many
celebrities who
fighting for women's rights together
zendaya and Bella reunited to be part of
history in the fight for equality a
friendship rooted in activism makes for
an incredibly strong bond we're willing
to bet they didn't compete with one
another at all that day
but then it all happened again in 2018
Bella and Sandhya were pitted against
each other by Latin 17 the mag posted a
side-by-side pic of zendaya and Bella on
Twitter with a hash tag Beauty battle
they posed a question about the former
co-stars that
Bella's and daya and their fans it asked
who looks better in this sensual red
lipstick seriously
Bella clapped back at the online mag
when she tweeted Beauty battle that's
not right
she wrote that it's been years and
people still want to pit her against her
co-star in some way she ended the tweet
by saying that she loves Sandhya fans
agreed with Bella one fan tweeted a
response insisting that people should
stop putting Bella and zendaya
against each other the fan added that
everyone should stop doing this in
general
she wrote that we are all different in
our own ways while we didn't see a
response from zendaya to this rediculous
beauty battle nonsense we're sure she
agrees with Bella it's hard to be
yourself the truth is what really
matters is how your friends support you
when you're going through a difficult
time Bella was recently the victim of
cyber invasion someone hacked into her
phone and stole some revealing photos of
her this hacker threatens Bella trying
to exploit her saying he was going to
expose the photos
this left Bella no choice but to expose
the pictures first so that her
blackmailer would have no way to profit
off her pictures she posted a tweet
saying she feels gross and that she
feels watched she posted the pictures on
Twitter commenting that her photos were
hacked and that she was being threatened
with their release she wrote that she
feels someone has taken something from
her that she wanted only one special
person to see she added that this person
also sent her pictures of other
celebrities and that the FBI will be
showing up at his door she also wrote
that she was taking her power back by
posting the photos herself the hackers
have since been arrested and are now
serving jail time later on the view
Whoopi Goldberg criticized Bella for
taking the photos in the first place you
don't take pictures of yourself this was
terribly upsetting to Bella her friends
and her fans Bella posted a tearful
Instagram story shaming Whoopi and
saying she did not deserve to have
sensitive photos used
to exploit her shame on you will be
shame on you zendaya backs Belle up she
told Bella that when she saw the video
of her crying about what Whoopi said to
her it broke her heart
zendaya texted Bella words of
encouragement saying she wanted to
remind her that she is strong and
beautiful inside and out
zendaya added that she believes Bella is
a light and that she's super proud of
her friend Bella said that she spoke
with Sandhya on the phone about changing
the negative ideas and behaviors
surrounding women's bodies they talked a
lot about their generation and agreed
that women shouldn't feel bad about
themselves or their bodies people
shaming women for their bodies is one of
the biggest struggles of her generation
Bella said so despite many highs and
lows zendaya and Bella are stronger
together and stronger than ever before
you go tell us who your favorite
celebrity BFFs are in the comment
section and that's a wrap
don't forget to Like and subscribe
thanks for watching the things we'll see
you next time
[Music]